Speaker 1: I have a very strange video for you.
I'm not going to spend a ton of time on this.
But Donald Trump issued another one of these
visibly confused statements in which he defends
the January six rioters. And there are so many
hypocrisies and double standards here. Let me
play the video first. And of course, Trump
says, oh, the country's going communist and
a lot of this normal stuff. Let's look
at the video, then we'll talk about it.
Speaker 5: Unconstitutionally, in my opinion,
and very, very unfairly. And we're going to
get to the bottom of it. And you know what
I've said, I take it very seriously. I have
never seen anything like it at all levels. It's
the weaponization of the Department of Justice.
And we can't let this happen in our country
because our country is going not socialist.
They've skipped over that. They skipped over
socialism. Our country is going communist now.
Speaker 1: Trump doesn't even know what either
of those terms mean, and he says this often at
rallies we went by, I used to say socialist,
but now I say communist. He has no clue what
he's talking about. Just remember that.
Speaker 5: It happens and we can't let it
happen. We have to stop it. So I want to thank
everybody for working so hard. I know how hard
you're working to get justice for people that
are imprisoned right now and people that are
being tormented. Can't let that happen. We're
going to stop it. We're going to win. Thank.
Speaker 1: Listen. Listen. Trump is talking.
What you might be wondering. What are they? What
are they? People are in prison. What do you mean?
Where people are being. People are being tortured.
Trump is talking about pretrial detention. Now
we have to take this piece by piece because this
is of such critical importance. First of all,
I'm not on the side of the criminals. Period.
Okay. As I always say, if BLM does something
and it's illegal. If Antifa does something and
it's illegal, there's, you know, if a protest of
whatever crimes, whether or not they are actually
part of those groups because as we know, mass
gatherings also bring out bad actors. And are
you really in BLM or. I don't care, guys. If you
commit crimes, you should be prosecuted. And if
you're convicted, you should be penalized. I
say it about Hunter Biden. I don't care about
political orientation and it's the same thing
with the rioters. Now, you look at the Capitol
breach cases, you can find the list. Okay. On the
website of the United States Attorney's Office for
the District of Columbia, Justice dot gov. You
can read through this and you'll see the names
of these folks and where they were arrested and
what they're accused of. And you see that there
are a number of different crimes. Many of these
are serious crimes. Our opinions matter less
about the individuals than about what is our
approach when we say we are for law and order.
When the Trump people say we are for law
and order, part of it means here is the law
and we have to allow the process to take place.
Now they are bringing up issues about the rioters
that they never cared about before. I'll give you
an example. Pretrial detention. I've talked about
pretrial detention on this program for more than
a decade. And pretrial detention is when you are
not given bail or you can't afford bail, you stay
in jail until the time of your trial. And I've
talked about how this is often used as a way or it
becomes a way in which individuals are less able
to build a defense. They're not able to afford
lawyers because they can't keep working while they
are, you know, maybe a better lawyer. They're not
because they're not able to work while they are in
pretrial detention, etc.. I've been talking about
it for a very long time and I've talked about how
pretrial detention disproportionately affects poor
people, minorities. It's we've talked about it.
These Republicans never cared about it. Now
they do because they see, hey, this pretrial
detention stuff is really unfair. They're keeping
all the rioters in jail until their trials. Yes,
we've been talking about it for a very long time.
It's not being used as a political weapon against
these people. This is the system. And we've
been complaining about it for a long time.
So there's the hypocrisy and there's the depravity
of saying we finally found people we believe are
worthy of our defense and they pick the Trump
rioters, which is absolutely crazy. How dare
the DOJ go after people many of whom are on video
committing crimes? That's unfair. It's a political
witch hunt. It's bonkers. And we are seeing the
sentences roll in. And that's a very good thing.